elon musk is known all over the world as
a multi-billionaire tech entrepreneur
that has disrupted multiple industries
like the automotive industry the private
space industry and the microfinance
industry but a lot of people don't
realize how frugal elon musk is with his
spending and his money elon musk is
known to have simple tastes and
dedicates most of his time to his work
so let us take a look at why with all
the money in the world elon musk is
living in a house that cost him a mere
fifty thousand dollars it was not always
like this elon musk owned multiple
properties when he was living in
california but in 2020 elon musk decided
to sell all the properties he owned one
by one he announced his decision via a
tweet saying i am selling almost all
physical possessions we'll own no house
in total that came to eight houses his
last house was a beautiful bay area
mansion that according to him held a
very special place in his heart this
property hit the market with a price tag
of 37.5 million dollars to understand
why elon musk was selling out all his
real estate in california we have to
also understand why elon musk moved from
california to texas elon musk started
his career in california he made his
initial millions there by starting
companies like zip2 and paypal for years
elon's companies like tesla and spacex
were headquartered in california spacex
was headquartered in the los angeles
area and tesla had its main offices in
palo alto so it is sufficient to say
that elon was pretty much settled in
california but for the past few years
elon started being disillusioned by the
californian dream and the benefits it
provided for a rising technology company
he had been pretty critical of high
income taxes in california and further
tax implications that basing his
businesses on headquarters would cost so
elon decided that it was time to move on
to greater pastures this was for a few
reasons number one taxes texas is
famously known for having no personal
income tax which would mean that elon
could save massively just by moving to a
different state number two the real
estate market in texas is a little bit
tamer than the market in california it
is more affordable and has more living
space as compared to the big california
cities another reason is that elon
decided to base his main starship
manufacturing facility in boca chica
texas a small village just off the coast
the reason for doing that is bokachika
is close to the equator making it easier
for spacex to launch their rockets elon
musk is living in a prefabricated
housing unit made by a company called
boxable he rents this fifty thousand
dollar property from spacex and lives on
site at starbase boca chica this
temporary home on the fly provides 375
square feet of living space according to
details on boxable's website each
housing unit comes with all the basic
appliances you would need that include a
large fridge a double sink with a view
an oven a dishwasher a microwave and a
shaker cabinetry the box-shaped house is
divided into four segments as you enter
the housing unit to your left is a small
kitchen and to your right is a living
room the kitchen has an extended table
top with chairs that you can use to sit
down and eat on as you go further into
the house you have a bedroom to the
right and a bathroom to the left the
bathroom comes with a shower a vessel
sink a large counter a backlit mirror
and sliding glass barn door in terms of
the living space according to boxable it
is about 19.5 feet by 19.5 feet with a
ceiling that is about nine feet six
inches high and eight foot high doors
the interior has a plank composite
flooring to give it a comfortable look
and the home comes with its heating and
air conditioning boxable also details
that they use very efficient insulation
and led bulbs to save power costs the
best part is that this whole unit can be
set up in a single day another great
thing about this prefabricated housing
unit is it is modular you can add more
units on top of it or side by side to
increase living space and since each
module itself is independent a single
unit can be towed by a vehicle like the
tesla model x no one can argue that it
is a very utilitarian design elon musk
has mentioned that he has installed
improvements to the home that do make
the house worth rise to about 69 000
which is still a modest property to live
in for someone with a net worth of 175
billion dollars from the sounds of it
this house is a cozy place and elon musk
is really excited about living in an
experimental module space like that but
still it makes you think that a
multi-billionaire chooses to live here
especially considering that there are
plenty of big mansions just a 30-minute
drive from the starbase facility at boca
chica texas elon is famous for his work
ethic and this is what drives most of
his decisions even the ones involving
selling all his properties and living in
a 50 000 house elon is known for
spending his nights at the office
sometimes sleeping on the couch or under
his desk during high workload weeks the
only explanation for his success can be
attributed to his insane work ethic elon
works himself to near death to meet his
goals and doesn't stop until they are
achieved for elon money and assets are
not luxuries but a means to an end he is
always looking for ways to use his money
to start a new venture and help solve a
new problem for mankind